hey there welcome to new rock stars it's
Sam basher whoa he's got a mustache whoa
and he's here to talk about Wanda vision
mmm yes the Disney Plus serie is slated
for a spring 2021 release all cards on
the table while I am a huge fan of
vision and Scarlet Witch this show
didn't really move the needle for me but
then more info came out about the cast
and this concept art from Marvel Studios
legend Andy Park showing vision in Wanda
in a 1950s era house with some creepy
Easter eggs hidden throughout and I just
knew this show was for me let's dive
into what we know about the series so
far what this is based off of and the
biggest question of all how is vision he
got his noggin caved in I've also got
some theories for this series being a
jumping-off point for the Young Avengers
but I'm getting ahead of myself spoiler
warning of course for endgame infinity
war Captain America Civil War you get it
first up what we know as for our stars
elizabeth Olsen Paul Bettany are
returning as Wanda Maximoff / Scarlet
Witch and vision respectively we're also
seeing the return of ant-man and the
wasp supporting actor Randall Park as
former SHIELD agent Jimmy woo and Thor
supporting actress Kat Benning as Darcy
Lewis oh where have you been for like a
decade we also know that Catherine ohan
will be joining the cast as a nosy
neighbor which is just perfect casting
their inclusion gets me very intrigued
but not as much as Tanya Parris taking
the role of Monica Rambeau the daughter
of Maria Rambo Carol Danvers friend from
Captain Marvel Monica famously was the
first woman in comics to take on the
mantle of Captain Marvel but is now
famously going by spectrum spectrum most
recently teamed up with Scarlet Witch
and vision in Avengers no Rhodes home
and is most well known for her crazy
power levels like in sane she's become
basically a being of pure energy that
can control all forms of electromagnetic
energy so he's pretty untouchable more
on how those supporting characters will
play into the story in a bit we learned
a while back though that this series
will be set in the 50s which is very
interesting looking at this concept art
you can see that clearly with this
idyllic 50s era suburban attire two
things to note here one this looks a
whole lot like Tom King and Gabriel
Walter's vision series from 2015 this
series followed vision as he built his
own nuclear family and tried to live a
suburban life fun fact his wife's brain
patterns were copied from Wanda's sounds
like a super healthy way to get over
your ex you can see some of that style
from the comic being mirrored in this
promotional art also we have writer Tom
Kane weighing in with this post this
looks an awful lot like the Dick Van
Dyke Show
sitcoms of that era I used that
succumbed specifically based on the
footage that was shown at d23 according
to the attendees at that conference the
promotion for one division showed clips
from Civil War and infinity war with one
and vision together along with clips
from the Dick Van Dyke Show specifically
scenes with Dick Van Dyke and Mary Tyler
Moore questioning their relationship
these scenes intercut with Wanda and
vision definitely leave you with a sense
of distrust whether the events are
actually happening and questioning what
is real but there's also transitioned us
to my favorite update this series is
gonna be the first sitcom in the MCU now
I know some of you may have grown on the
other side of this screen but think
about it one has gone through a lot in
her young life she grew up in a war-torn
country was experimented on by Hydra
lost her brother accidentally killed
civilians and Lagos had the Avengers and
the world turn on her and she loses her
Robo lover twice to Thanos and then gets
snapped out of existence after returning
she may be a wee bit interested into
looking to make her life a little bit
more simple
maybe she's able to create a false
reality with the help of her mental
manipulation powers telekinesis and
possibly reality slash probability
warping powers from the comics a reality
similar to a sitcom that she grew up
loving where the audience actively love
and appreciate the characters we see
on-screen where she can finally feel
accepted Elizabeth Olsen even joked
saying that the producers were deciding
if they wanted to add a laugh track or
not please the creators behind this show
have discussed that the facade will
collapse pretty quickly once the show
begins and turn into something truly
epic something that we come to expect
from the MCU now let's dive into what we
could be seeing in the series looking at
the concept art we see both of our
characters Wanda and vision in their
classic color schemes red for Wanda and
a mix of purple green and yellow for
vision but we've also got a haunting
shadow of their super selves with the
first appearance of Wanda's classic face
mask along with the mine stone or
possibly the solar jewel that absorbs
sunlight like in the comics right back
there on the wall you can see a little
bomb you'll also notice the idyllic 50s
coloring stops just outside the light
from the TV which seems to be giving off
some sort of scarlet witch's red energy
my theory is that Wanda is diving deep
into what she's capable of in the comic
events like house of M we seen Wanda
change all of reality to suit her will
she can manifest just about anything
into reality if she chooses to could she
possibly be creating a fake
in a real suburb that draws the
attention of her neighbors and possibly
the superhero community this could lead
to Jimmy woo former agent of shield
turned FBI agent teaming up with Darci
Lewis a grad student who has been
studying interdimensional energies with
Jane Foster and Erik Selvig to find out
what is going on in this quiet suburban
neighborhood this could also lead to
Monica Rambeau showing up to either gain
her abilities due to this reality
warping nonsense or could be the only
asset the Jimmy Wu has to take on the
Scarlet Witch also worth mentioning Wynn
Scarlet Witch created the house of
x-reality it was because she was powered
up by a demon named chip on a literal
devil
now Scarlet Witch has had run-ins with
Devils in the past so as vision actually
famously it was revealed that their tu
children were not created from Wanda's
powers no they were from Mephisto now
Mephisto is another popular devil in
Marvel Comics and I have a feeling that
he might be safer a larger story in the
MCU but I could 100% seeing wander using
the powers of something sinister to
bring back the one that she loves
another cool side note chick Don is tied
to the dark old evil mystical book from
Marvel Comics which appeared in a season
of agents of shield which they showed
was a book that was stolen from the
library of karma Taj the place where
Doctor Strange trained to be the
sorcerer supreme kind of cool how it all
comes together might make ages the
shield important so either one is
bringing vision literally back from the
dead or she's reaching into the
multiverse or an alternate timeline and
bringing vision back to this one this
could also be a good lead-in to Wanda
join Doctor Strange in multiverse of
madness she might be making a little bit
of a mess that she's gonna need to clean
up either way this is a solid way to
keep the stakes high for this series and
to make this really feel like a true
1950s era sitcom is to make it just not
a story about a happy couple in the
suburbs but a happy family
we know from interviews with the cast
and crew that they're pulling from
multiple comic storylines so why not
throw in Scarlet Witch envisions kids
Wiccan and speed these characters
famously popped up in the Young Avengers
comic and were confirmed by Scarlet
Witch to have the souls of their
children residing inside them you know
again turned out to be manifestations of
Mephisto so the whole thing is a little
confusing and convoluted but pretty cool
just have them be from another timeline
or from another universe similar to
what's going on with the Loki series on
super down if Wan division deals with
the multiverse like how Loki series is
going to be dealing with the alternate
Loki from another timeline that stole
the tesseract in
also these kids make it out of the
series add them to the mix with Kate
Bishop from the Hawkeye series and
Comicon from the Miss Marvel series and
you got yourself either a Young Avengers
series for a Champions team-up show in
the works what do you think could Scott
witch be manipulated by dark forces into
making a deal that brings a vision back
to the land of the living
could he be from an alternate timeline
an alternate universe let me know down
below don't forget to Like and subscribe
and follow me at San basher and send me
your thoughts and theories on Twitter
check our new rockstars a rogue theory
I'm on an episode of that and until next
time I'm Sam basher
[Music]